[Musica]
ieri ho incontrato a pranzo un compagno
di scuola che fa l'avvocato e ci siamo
raccontati un po delle nostre storie
professionali
quando ha sentito che io mi occupo di
tecnologie spaziali mi ha posto un
quesito molto importante mi ha detto ma
è davvero il caso di investire tutti
questi soldi nello spazio quando abbiamo
problemi così importanti come
cambiamenti climatici
l'uso dissennato di risorse essenziali
come la terra come l'acqua e questo è un
punto importante ovviamente io sono
convinto che il caso ma per aiutare a
convincerlo dove articolare un
ragionamento in maniera adeguata e
quindi sono partito dalla considerazione
più semplice tutto lo sviluppo
tecnologico determina ricadute in cose
con le quali abbiamo a che fare
quotidianamente e che quindi possono
dare un beneficio immediato alla nostra
vita quotidiana
per esempio è il caso della tecnologia
di aspirazione che è stata utilizzata
per degli astronauti che dovevano
raccogliere dei campioni sulla luna e
che oggi è utilizzata per i nostri
aspirapolvere ma sicuramente è vero
anche per microchip per la
microelettronica che è stata spinta in
avanti proprio per le esigenze che le
tecnologie spaziali esprimevano ma mi
rendo conto che questo non è così
convincente allora ho spinto un pochino
ho detto e anche le ricadute ci sono nel
settore sanitario che già più vicino
alle nostre sensibilità e quindi ho
fatto riferimento al latte artificiale
alle protesi meccaniche di arti alle
pompe ventricolari è sicuramente un
esempio ancora più calzante viene
proprio da questa immagine dove si vede
non una galassia ma si vede un una
radiografia di un seno dove ci sono dei
puntini che sono formazioni tumorali in
fase iniziale
ecco quei puntini oggi è possibile
discriminarli in questa immagine grazie
alla messa a punto di un algoritmo che
serviva a migliorare il funzionamento
del 3
scoppio spaziale hubble bè capisco però
che se lavoriamo solo sugli benefici
indotti non sarò così convincente quanto
voglio essere
e allora mi concentro su quello che sono
effettivamente invece gli indirizzi
diretti dei sistemi spaziali nella
nostra vita quotidiana e cominciò per
esempio con i sistemi di osservazione
della terra
allora cominciamo a pensare per esempio
alla tutela dell'ambiente
vedete questa immagine questa è l'isola
dei canguri in australia e bellissima
colorata ma in realtà è il risultato di
una devastazione di un incendio
satellite ci consentono con le diverse
colorazioni di identificare i danni che
questi incendi ha prodotto ma
soprattutto ci consentono di analizzare
meglio la vegetazione ex ante per capire
come mai l'incendio si è propagato in
quelle modalità e perché dove i danni
sono stati maggiori
questo è stato possibile e questo ci
permetterà ha già permette di evitare in
modo predittivo che queste che questi
incendi così profondi possono
svilupparsi e soprattutto ci permetterà
di minimizzare gli effetti e per pensare
già in tempo misure per ridurre questi
rischi
in realtà di questi impieghi ce ne sono
tantissimi pensiamo per esempio
all'agricoltura
ovviamente oggi dobbiamo immaginare che
nel 2050 si prevede che nel mondo sulla
terra ci saranno nove miliardi di
persone ben nove miliardi di persone
consumano una quantità impressionante di
cibo e quindi di conseguenza anche di
risorse pregiate
perché se per esempio considerarsi mo
sempre ogni giorno che consumiamo un
piatto di pasta che però per produrre un
chilo di pasta ci vogliono 2 mila litri
d'acqua
immaginiamo per un attimo quanta pasta
cioè sugli scaffali del supermercato e
quanti supermercati ci sono
nostre città e quanti si permette htc
sono nel mondo
allora dobbiamo assolutamente
concentrarci sulla necessità di
preservare l'utilizzo di quella risorsa
ma soprattutto anche di ridurre il più
possibile l'utilizzo di fertilizzanti
che sicuramente inducono altri rischi
altri problemi sulla nostra salute
per fare questo i satelliti ci vengono
incontro perché è possibile osservare
grandi produzioni agricole grandi
distese di territorio e identificare i
luoghi dove l'acqua è necessario e dove
non lo è
identificare i luoghi dove i
fertilizzanti sono necessari dove non lo
sono e quindi in qualche modo
efficientare l'uso dell'acqua e ridurre
al massimo i fertilizzanti mantenendo
altissimo il livello della qualità della
produzione e quindi la capacità di
alimentare quei nove miliardi di persone
ma gli stessi 9 miliardi di persone nel
2050 si prevede che vivranno almeno per
il 70 per cento nei grandi insediamenti
urbani allora c'è un altro grosso
problema che dobbiamo affrontare
affrontare per per la tutela
dell'ambiente che è quello di costruire
delle città
oggi ci piace chiamarle smart cities da
costruire delle città dove si possa
coniugare la sicurezza la salute di
fondo in fondo la felicità del di chi ci
abita
anche qui i satelliti ci vengono
incontro e ci vengono incontro già oggi
figuriamoci nel 2050 che cosa possiamo
fare questa telli per le smart cities ma
almeno mi vengono in mente tre esempi
uno è la guida autonoma i mezzi a guida
autonoma
i satelliti possono aiutarci con una
precisione ormai di 10 cm a muovere dei
sistemi sul nella superficie terrestre e
quindi anche nei grandi centri urbani
questo immaginate per un attimo potrebbe
consentire a un certo punto di non avere
più il traffico cittadino di avere un
utilizzo efficiente dei ma e dei mezzi
in mobilità e di avere degli spazi
liberati da quelli che oggi sono
parcheggi e magari creare
il verde delle aree dove possono giocare
i bambini
e sicuramente una emissione di co2
assolutamente ridotte e su questo
sicuramente i satelliti ci possono dare
una bella mano
in realtà possiamo fare anche altro la
prosa di guida autonoma possiamo guidare
oggetti che volano i droni sistemi a
pilotaggio remoto e questi droni possono
aiutarci possono migliorare le
condizioni della vita in un centro
urbano perché per esempio possono
aiutare la consegna di beni e servizi ma
soprattutto possono operare in
condizioni di emergenza già oggi abbiamo
fatto recentemente una una
sperimentazione per muovere dei campioni
biologici da due punti diversi
dell'ospedale pediatrico bambino gesù di
roma
in modalità veloce sicura e che quindi
possa garantire il risultato per
l'emergenza figuriamoci nel 2050 ma si
può fare ancora di più nelle smart
cities c'è un fenomeno nelle grandi
città che sicuramente con i satelliti
possiamo migliorare si tratta delle
isole di calore che di fatto nei periodi
più torridi dell'anno più caldi
dell'anno
abbiamo delle delle zone della città
dove ristagna il calore anche durante la
notte e questo chiaramente espone a
rischio soprattutto i cittadini più
deboli quindi gli anziani i bambini
vedete questa immagine questa è la
misura in una grande città italiana di
isole calore di calore registrate in
pieno agosto
queste sono state registrate con un
satellite che si chiama sentinel 3 del
della costellazione copernico st europea
bene abbiamo detto che ci sono delle
delle parti della popolazione più
fragili che sono a rischio in queste in
queste condizioni allora andiamo a
guardare in quest'altra mappa dove sono
presenti dove risulta essere presenti
nella stessa città una maggiore densità
di popolazione di anziani di bambini e
se incrociamo questi due dati con
un'ultima mappa
accorgiamo anche dove è possibile fare
degli interventi di protezione di
prevenzione
allora capiamo bene che il satellite qui
sta dando un grandissimo contributo alla
salute e alla continuità della vita
umana e questo è possibile in senso
generale perché i satelliti ci possono
aiutare a supportare le emergenze con la
capacità di individuare la stessa mente
dei danni ma soprattutto anche quello
che è necessario fare per raggiungere
portare i soccorsi a chi ha subito ed è
presente nella zona delle emergenze e
questo ormai è già così è già
un'esperienza che viviamo
quotidianamente allora capisco che lo
stavo quasi convincendo il mio amico
però viviamo un'epoca difficile la
pandemia al co lead 19 quindi il dubbio
viene e quindi è con il como 19 che cosa
fanno i satelliti non risolvono certo il
problema della pandemia
certamente no i satelliti non risolvono
il problema della pandemia ma anche qui
ci aiutano ci hanno ci stanno aiutando
in questo periodo hanno consentito e
consentono tuttora di osservare i
comportamenti umani ea e dare un
contributo anche a chi è preposto a
garantire che vengano rispettate una
serie di regole per per governare la
gestione dell'emergenza ma possono anche
misurare la situazione dell'andamento
economico del paese
per capire come l'emergenza sta
incidendo nel nel tessuto più più
profondo della nostra economia e possono
mettere a rete e tutti quegli attori o
tanti degli attori che fanno parte del
sistema che gestisce l'emergenza
pandemica con delle comunicazioni sicure
che consentono anche in condizioni come
questa di governare sistemi complessi
e a proposito di comunicazioni alla
tocchiamo un altro tasto per essere
ancora più convincenti le comunicazioni
satellitari sono probabilmente l'ambito
dove il satellite ha cominciato dapprima
di tutti a dare un grande contributo
alla vita quotidiana
pensate che
l'estate led comunication sono nate nel
1945 per la fantasia di un giovane
autore di fantascienza fondamentalmente
che scrisse un articolo che gli è stato
pubblicato e che peraltro si è stato
pagato 15 sterline
arthur clarke in quest'articolo lui
immaginava che era possibile comunicare
mettere in comunicazione tutti gli
abitanti del mondo attraverso solo tre
diciamo satelliti oggi lui immaginava
delle macchine che potessero essere
disposte lontane dalla superficie della
terra in una modalità tale che potessero
governare e controllare le comunicazioni
in tutta la superficie
ecco vent'anni dopo questo era vero
questo era il risultato di quelle che
sono tutt'oggi le comunicazioni
satellitari con i satelliti
geostazionari disposte 36.000 chilometri
dalla terra
e l'italia venti anni dopo si era già
dotata di queste capacità
tant'è vero che nel 69 abbiamo potuto
assistere della mia generazione ero
bambina ho visto tito stagno che
commentava le immagini dell'uomo che
toccava la superficie della luna e
quelle immagini venivano da huston e
quindi avevano era possibile che
raggiungessero la televisione nella casa
dei miei genitori
proprio perché c'erano i fratelli e
delle comunicazioni in questi decenni
questi satelliti hanno aumentato e
sviluppato ulteriormente le loro
capacità e oggi consentono anche di
rispondere a un'esigenza fondamentale
che è quella del dell'accesso ad
internet che risponde a un altro
problema sociale che il dg audi raid di
giardi weyden non è altro un modo per
dire che anche nei paesi ricchi anche
nei paesi dove pensiamo di avere
raggiunto un livello di capacità e
conoscenza in realtà abbiamo ancora
bambini e questa è una storia che
sentiamo tutti i giorni l'ho sentita
giorni fa e mi ha colpito bambini che
per ricevere lezioni incolla didattica a
distanza devono percorrere 5 chilometri
per andare nel paese vicino perché nel
suo paese
nel loro paese non hanno la connettività
ecco i satelliti riescono a sopperire a
questa esigenza
perché hanno la capacità di osservare
una grande zona e di garantire in quella
zona connettività di internet con
prestazioni e costi assolutamente
adeguati
beh allora direi che tutto ciò è più che
convincente sono guardando negli occhi
il mio amico ho capito che l'aveva
convinta
d'altra parte io sono molto convinto e
quindi forse ci metto anche la passione
nella mia spiegazione perché non sono un
ingegnere che ha dedicato buona parte
della sua vita a queste tecnologie
però il vero problema non è tanto la mia
convinzione è il fatto che le tecnologie
satellitari sono un mattone per la
sostenibilità e non possiamo rinunciare
ad esse questo è il vero punto grazie
[Musica]